welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Star Wars Return of the Jedi
marked the then conclusion to an
all-time greatest film trilogy that
would actually be a never-ending stream
of film series games Android building
workshops at Disneyland
despite its divisive elements return to
the Jedi remains a sacred installment to
the franchise perhaps because as the
most family-friendly of the original
trilogy it was really the Star Wars film
many of us saw first as kids
Ewoks got us in the door which is kind
of like the minions being your gateway
to the deeper complex mythology have
grew in the despicable me saga there's a
lot there be sure to check out my past
breakdowns of a new hope and the Empire
Strikes Back but now let us point out
all the interesting visual details and
Easter eggs that make Return of the Jedi
such a classic the opening crawl reveals
the title Return of the Jedi originally
George Lucas and co-writer Larry Kasdan
wanted to title it to Revenge of the
Jedi but Lucas argued that revenge kinda
went against the Jedi Code and as an
Arthurian fantasy trilogy modeled partly
on Tolkien's Lord of the Rings trilogy
return of the maid for a fitting title
of the third the opening words of the
crawl are Luke Skywalker has returned
apparently identifying Luke as the
returning Jedi of the title but this of
course is a misdirect many Star Wars
films possess titles that seem to refer
to one thing at the start of the film it
actually referred to another and return
to the Jedi refers not to Luke but to
his father Anakin Skywalker making this
story one of redemption after
collaborating with Irvin Kershner for
Empire George Lucas commissioned for
Return of the Jedi director Richard
Marquand who described Lucas's
dominating presence and vision on set as
like trying to direct King Lear with
Shakespeare in the next room as a result
Return of the Jedi returns from the
character development of Empire to the
things George Lucas has been more
interested in world building and can
belly and symbolism Lucas was a
proponent of the storytelling philosophy
of Joseph Campbell which states that all
heroes of mythology go on cyclical
journeys that lead them to return to
their origin point having undergone a
transformation as a film Return of the
Jedi does this by repeating several of
the story beats of the new hope once
again the Empire is building a Death
Star
once again Luke finds himself on
Tatooine but in both cases the game is
the same but the players have changed
the film begins with a parallel image to
the opening of a new hope a Star
Destroyer when Jean down into frame with
a true returning Jedi of this film at
Darth Vader Vader presses Mothe chair
Jerrod to move
ambassador to complete this second Death
Star I love how Jerry Jerrod goes as
Vader approaches likely having heard all
the stories about all the other Imperial
officers Vader forced choked to death so
why this hurry well if you think about
it the Emperor's political strategy
depends on having the Death Star as an
unmatched apocalyptic deterrent
maintaining order through fear when the
rebels destroyed the first in the Battle
of Yavin the Emperor's symbolic power
was threatened
so the fragility of that fear signals a
weakness in the Emperor that Luke can
later exploit r2d2 and c3po arrive at
the palace of Jabba the Hutt originally
in 1983 this was the first time
audiences saw Jabba in the flesh so much
flesh despite the cgi version of him
that was added to the anewhopeee 1997
special edition this Jabba was a half
million dollar two thousand pound puppet
that required six people to operate
including one for separate movement of
the mouth the eyelids the tongue the
inside of his hangout is styled to evoke
the Mos Eisley cantina but with more
elaborate character designs and culture
like his guards are the pig nose
gomorian sand he's flanked by a male
Twi'lek advisor named bib Fortuna and a
jester like pet a koala a lizard named
salacious crumb there are Jawas present
in live music from the max rebo band max
is the blue elephant looking dude who
plays the red ball jet organ this band
includes lead vocals from sighs neutrals
who is animated with CGI for the special
edition along with a new singer Joe
yowza whose voice was based on a singer
Joe Cocker
[Music]
they sing this song titled lap T neck
which is Huttese for work it out it was
written by John Williams son Joseph
Williams from the band Toto next to
arrive is the Bounty Hunter Bush
bringing Chewbacca
now bushes of course Leia in disguise on
her helmet or the numbers 1-1 3-8 one of
many of George Lucas's nods to his
previous film thx 1-1 3-8
also in disguises Lando Calrissian
pretending to be Tam tell screams from a
legend story but in solo Beckett words
disguise on Kessel suggesting that in
the film Canon Lando founded on the
Falcon Leia thaws Han but she also ends
up one of Jabba's possessions and wearer
of a metal bikini that would shatter the
innocence of Comic Con attendees for
decades to come with all the pieces in
place Luke arrives now I pointed out
before how the color of Luke's clothes
changed throughout the film white and a
new hope gray an empire and now black
and Jedi reflecting his descent into the
dark side to rescue his father he first
appears as a hooded silhouette similar
to Vader's arrival in the first film and
e-force chokes the guards as dad's
favorite move when a Jedi mind-trick
probably would have worked here Luke
defeats the rancor by dropping the gate
on its head
this results in tears from the
Beastmaster named Malachy Lee if you're
wondering the story behind this guy
according to Lord this rancor has a name
p'tee see and it actually saved Malachy
Lee's life during a Tuscan Raider attack
and he planned to one day escape with a
beast before Luke killed it they're
taken to the Sarlacc which george lucas
updated from the original version a pit
with teeth and tendrils to a more
visible beast with a large beak I used
to live here
actually according to Canon when Luke
was a kid it was a popular dare among
his friends to jump the Sarlacc pit and
a low-flying sand skimmer which is
partly why he's so unafraid of it here
Luke makes his big move having our
tubelaunch to him his new green
lightsaber now originally Luke's new
saber was going to be blue like his old
one was you looked at early trailers and
posters it was blue there but a scene
showing Luke assembling and activating
his new saber was cut from the film so
to avoid confusion that this wasn't the
same lightsaber that he lost on Cloud
City they changed the color
Luke wildly swings a lightsaber to
attack Jabba's men where is the
lightsaber action of the first two films
was more confined limited mostly to
duels in taunton surgery this film draws
more upon the swashbuckling stunts of
pirate films and air
flin movies luke's jedi knight skills
are so deadly that he can now force kick
the air to disarm and take down guess
that is how i choose to interpret this
boba fett suffers a sadly unceremonious
death after hun knocks his jet pack by
accident George Lucas later said that
had he known both Fett was going to be
so popular he would have given him a
more memorable death and he considered
adding a shot of good with that escaping
the Sarlacc pit for the 2004 DVD release
Boba Fett also escapes the Sarlacc and
Legends lore but this is yet to be
confirmed true in cinematic Canon they
curse crush the Mandalorian makes Patton
Oswalt's dream come true the gloved
Mandalorian armor gauntlet of Boba Fett
grabs onto the sand outside the char Lac
pit and the feared bounty hunter pulls
himself from the maw Leia uses her slave
chains to choke Jabba a death meant as
an homage to the death of Luca Brasi in
The Godfather the director of which
Francis Ford Coppola is Lucas's longtime
friend and inspiration for the character
of Han Solo they blow the yacht and
escape and when Luke takes off the next
wing there's a close-up of his machine
hand reminding us of his increase in
anatomical similarity to his father
Luke's hand is the unhealable wound
archetype similar to Frodo's shoulder
the physical impairment that never fully
heals to symbolize their burden and the
way evil is attempting to corrupt them
and speaking evil that Emperor arrives
and will only be calling them the
Emperor here because he was not named
Palpatine or Darth Sidious until later
originally this was in McDiarmid first
appearance in the role with the part
played by Marjorie Eaton and voiced by
Clive rebel in the Empire Strikes Back
before Lucas Reata to that scene in 2004
McDiarmid was initially just brought in
to play the physical part of the
character but he impressed Lucas with
his wicked demonic voice he based that
voice on a Japanese method of channeling
a base residence through your stomach
resulting in this guttural croak that is
now so iconic it's not hard to do it
just doing on Dagobah Yoda confirms that
Vader is Luke's father he also tells him
that's worth noting that Yoda does not
say kill Vader only confront it's been a
foreshadowing of Luke's solution to
overcoming Vader not by violence but by
conversion of values George Lucas made
Yoda declare this truth because he said
after consulting with a child
psychologist moviegoers ages 12 and
under would dismiss Vader's claim to be
a lie unless it was unequivocally stated
by the most trusted elder of this
universe in my view everything that
pissed people off about return to the
Jedi originated from this child
psychologist session because Return of
the Jedi marked the moment the Star Wars
franchise changed to become family films
to be fair this is what got me on board
with the series as a five-year-old but
you know over the years has it grown up
who sometimes acts like a five-year-old
it kind of sucks to hear the directions
this film almost went for example both
Harrison Ford and Larry Kasdan wanted
Han Solo to be killed off but Lucas
reportedly responded to that that he
didn't see much of a future in dead han
toys and tell that to the hon in
carbonite rug similarly Endor was
originally going to be a wookie planet
but Lucas insisted that the furry
creatures be smaller and closer to teddy
bears now the fact that later films
showed us both Kashyyyk and Hans death
proves that eventually everything we
want from Star Wars will happen Yodas
final words are another confirmation
completing his sentence from that
lingering cliffhanger from the Empire
Strikes Back further clarification is
provided by Obi Wan's ghost who now uses
some verbal gymnastics to explain how
Anakin's darkside vader killed Anakin's
light side when he took over and he
helps him realize that Leia is his twin
sister
I guess my sister old man Obi Wan's
deception was designed to make it easier
for Luke to kill his father to see him
purely as evil but that feeling of
betrayal in subpeona part of the reason
Luke is able to defy his mentor's to
take a different approach toward Vader
the rebel fleet regroups led politically
by mon mothma and militarily by Admiral
Akbar Akbar is a Mon Calamari from the
ocean covered world of Mon Cala and
according to Canon he was once the slave
interpreter and personal pilots of Grand
Moff Tarkin from whom he learned
Imperial strategy before he was freed
and rose through the ranks to become
leader of the rebel military Mothma
shares new Intel about the second Death
Star and that the emperor would be on it
interestingly Star Wars lore expands on
the Bothans known for their spy net and
their operation to steal an imperial
computer one that we learned later this
film the Emperor actually allowed them
to steal really only about a couple
dozen boffins died and this universe
billions of people die constantly but
bathin politicians loved painting them
as heroic martyrs for years to come and
mothma as a politician is using this
sacrifice to motivate the rebel fleet
here before I continue thank you to our
sponsor for this episode epic games in
their Star Wars fallen order game the
new third-person action adventure game
which you could download yourself by
clicking on the link below while an
order takes place after the events of
Revenge of the Sith when the Jedi have
been purged in the galaxy at the ODA 66
of Emperor Palpatine who you play as an
escaped Padawan who joins up with some
resistance members to rebuild the Jedi
Order
I've joked before about the youngling
hoots Anakin Skywalker into the Sith you
know what that's not funny we should all
have more empathy for what these poor
kids went through the game looks
incredible and super fun to play and if
you enjoy Star Wars mythology or if you
just like cutting stormtroopers in half
with a lightsaber you're definitely
gonna want to jump on this Star Wars
Jedi pol and order is available in the
epic game store for 59.99 when you
download it from the epic game store you
get a free stormtrooper skin in
fortnight use my link below to download
Star Wars Jedi file and order yourself
and use my support a creator code new
rock stars who help support the channel
thanks again - at the games for
sponsoring this episode they had to the
forest moon of Endor in addition to
wookies instead of Ewoks cast an also
wanted to replace this setting of Endor
with what would have been the imperial
capital called had Abadan which was
later renamed in Cannon as course on
Endor was shot in the redwood forest of
Northern California with its name taken
from the Bible in which King Saul
encountered the Witch of Endor which is
a village in Israel they get spotted by
scout troopers whom they pursue in a
thrilling speeder bike chase these point
of view shots were achieved by having a
camera operator with a Steadicam walk
backward through the forest at normal
speed with the camera capturing one
frame every few seconds and then later
they reversed that footage and played it
back at 24 frames per second speeding up
the footage by 5,000% Leia meets the
Ewok wicket to play by Warwick Davis as
a boy it was his first foam roll and he
would go on to play several W named
characters in the Star Wars films the
name Ewok is derived from my walk the
name of Native American tribes
indigenous to Northern California where
the indoor scenes were shot the Ewok
language is based on the kalmyk language
of Buddhist tribes in southern Russia
Vader meets with the emperor in his
throne room now his observation window
is clearly designed to resemble a
spider's web with the Emperor as the
spider in the center the main plot of
this film is an elaborate trap set by
the Emperor
yeah we know a trap designed to crush
the rebellion and convert Luke to be
successor to Vader and one swift motion
though note that while Vader felt Luke's
presents the it's a little moment that
foreshadows how the connection between
Vader and Luke is stronger than the
power of the Emperor Emperor is powerful
that limitedly so but he's alone and
this film suggests that the power family
in connection will always overcome any
power achieved in isolation the others
are brought to an Ewok camp to be eaten
but they're saved by Leia and Threepio
whom the Ewoks worship as a God the same
way that Yoda used the force to lift
technology to inspire faith in Luke Luke
does the same with Threepio to inspire
faith in the Ewoks
Threepio regales the Ewoks with the
story of their adventures which coming
from a deity figure must come off as a
kind of religious parable to them
originally George Lucas conceived of
Star Wars as a legend from what he
called the Journal of the Wills a
biblical text that would have been
passed down from a future alien race
called the wills before leaving Luke
talks with Leia
a draft of the script actually went into
more detail about their mother saying
she was disguised as a handmaid of her
adoptive parents whom were later laved
bail and braja Organa the prequels
revised this of course a Padme who died
in childbirth though since Padme would
disguise herself as a handmaid on Naboo
some have speculated Leia in that draft
was forced remembering Padme is passed
and then Luke tells Leia that Vader is
his father well actually their father
John Williams underscores Leia's
realization with a new theme for this
film the Luke and Leia theme
somehow mmm always I assume she means
her hearing Luke's voices he called to
her from Cloud City not a anything that
happened before that Luke's surrenders
himself to Vader boldly attempting to
appeal to his father's robot heart I
know there is good in you the Emperor
hasn't driven it from you fully that was
why you couldn't destroy me
I loved the blocking choice of Luke
turning his back to the man he last
faced an epic duel it signals to his
father that he is not there to confront
him with violence but Vader responds to
this gesture with a threat but in doing
so Luke has led his father to an
opportunity to wield a Jedi lightsaber
once more to remind his father the
feeling Luke felt when he first
activated Anakin's old lightsaber and
Obi Wan's home and noticed how that
tactic shifts the power dynamic of the
scene Vader lowers the blade and he
turns away as well and for the first
time he reveals his inner waiter
describes himself as a slave to a
greater evil beyond his control the
first time he has said he's not in full
control of something but and do it so he
reciprocates Luke repeatedly calling him
father
by calling Luke son and that is enough
of a signal to Luke that his father can
still be saved
the Ewoks the rebels surround the shield
generator base and Han makes this
sickest moved the whole Star Wars
franchise inside the base hun kills an
armed Imperial officer by chucking junk
across the room at him
this is actually a cameo by sound
designer ben burtt that screamy does is
his best approximation of the famous
Wilhelm scream a sound effect that Burt
made iconic with his work on these films
among the rebel fleet are the B wing
fighters but since their thin profile
makes them hard to see on screen the B
wings were actually removed from the
later part of the battle Akbar commands
from his flagship home one and leading
the strike is Lando Calrissian piloting
a falcon with copilot knee and on the
Death Star Luke and Vader meet the
Emperor who reveals the coming rebel
attack was all according to his plan
what I like about this is that both of
them are correct
Luke's faith and his friends is a
weakness this weakness led him to give
up on his Jedi training in the Empire
Strikes Back and run after them to Cloud
City confronting Vader before he was
ready but that weakness also gives Luke
humanity which becomes a strength by
giving them an ally in Vader that human
connection is what the Emperor lacks and
as Luke tells them his hubris creates a
blind spot to Vader than one person
powerful enough to destroy him the fleet
scrambles as they realize I know
meanwhile the captured rebels are saved
by the Ewoks they use a variety of
guerrilla tactics tripwires catapult
swinging logs their success was actually
modeled on the vietcong's guerrilla
tactics in the Vietnam War with more
primitive natural forces overcoming a
seemingly superior technological force
and to accentuate the surface level
drama this war the camera lingers on
some of the casualties
[Music]
least as a kid I cried at this stuff as
an adult it kind of rolled my eyes just
as I did the mouth Keely but now were
you watching it you've gotta love the
choice to linger on the grief that this
warfare causes chewy lets out a Tarzan
yell as he swings on to an 80 st inside
the pilots are actually cameos by
director Richard Marquand and
co-producer Robert watts and the battle
ends with this great callback I love the
thing that inspires Hahn to say I love
you is Lea hiding a blaster ready to
shoot first
just as Hahn actually did degree toe but
clunky for everyone throughout all this
the Emperor temps Luke to get into his
anger over his friends dying from an
actually operational desk our super
laser which makes Luke snap as a
contrast to their previous duel this
time Luke initiates and Bader is now
reactive and notices how their blades
clash over the Emperor's smile it's
because the Emperor is actually Luke's
true opponent in this duel where as
Vader is just a tool of the Emperor
Lucca kicks Vader down the steps make us
in contact this time I like Albert
included a subtle scratch of Vader's
lightsaber on the steps as he flips
Luke counters Vader's awesome saber toss
with a furious charge evoked by Vader
threatening Leia the camera dollies left
as Luke beats his father back until
finally as Vader did to Luke on Cloud
City Luke hacks off his hand
luca gazes down at his prosthetic hand
in the back of his father's now stump
and realizes that he again is playing
right into the emperor's trap Luke has
become the fury driven Emperor
apprentice that his father was and one
that if he continues on this path will
inevitably be replaced
probably by his nephew so when Luke
rejects the Emperor the look of disgust
from the Emperor is the scariest that we
ever see him because for once things are
no longer going according to his plan
he's threatened and knows in this moment
that he has lost this war because Luke's
values of family of connection of
redemption have triumphed over the
Emperor's values of ambition aggression
and power so he uses sit lightening on
Luke his use of Sith lightning on Luke
is really just the savage gnashing of a
wounded animal as Luke screams in agony
Vader's inner humanity finally surfaces
[Music]
[Music]
and down goes the Emperor well until JJ
Abrams brings it back now I also noticed
that Bader said no rule here this was
added later to the special edition
originally he was silent Lucas went back
and redubbed the know similar to the one
in Revenge of the Sith perhaps who
linked Anakin's grief over losing child
in that moment to almost losing that
child again also notice that the Sith
lightning illuminates a skull under
Vader's mask implying that there is a
human face underneath that helmet and
John Williams underscores this victory
with a light motif to the heroic force
theme reflecting Vader's return to the
light side of the force and now wounded
his iconic breathing has changed forever
[Music]
with the shield down Lando is leading
the raid into the Death Star and he
knocks off the Falcons dish a callback
to the scratch that he promised Han he
wouldn't get on it but before it blows
Luke unmasks his father revealing whoa
not the face James Earl Jones powerful
voice had us expecting but that of actor
sebastian shaw pale bald scarred the
2004 DVD release reduced Shaw's eyebrows
to be more consistent with Anakin's
burns and Revenge of the Sith
they also made him even paler which
reflects how under that mask Anakin's
appearance was gradually transitioning
into something akin to the Emperor I'll
not leave you here I've got to save you
if it hurts to see the most memorable
film villain get dismantled like this
that's by design when damaged souls find
redemption the seemingly cool outer
layer of them melts down into something
kind of ugly but honest and true
redemption is not a butterfly
transformation following the death star
explosion and Anakin's funeral by fire
the final minutes of Return of the Jedi
have been drastically altered in later
editions the 1997 special edition added
to the celebration montage Cloud City
Tatooine and the soon to be introduced
in Phantom Menace Coruscant including
the Emperor statue being toppled and a
crowd-surfing stormtrooper emitting
another Wilhelm scream the 2004 DVD
release added Naboo to the celebration
and a chorus onto the Senate building
and Jedi Temple in the background all of
these changes I'm okay with except Luke
sees the force ghosts of obi-wan and
Yoda joined by his father Anakin but in
2004 in every edition onward they
replaced Sebastian Shaw with Hayden
Christensen Anakin from the prequels
George Lucas said he changed it because
I guess he wanted the Anakin at the end
of the film to be the Anakin before he
transitioned to Vader and fairness to
Hayden Christensen the actor said that
when he shot this he didn't understand
what Lucas would use it for and if he
did he would have played it totally
different the problem is the Anakin of
the entire final act of Revenge of the
Sith had already become Vader he became
Vader when he let mace windu die when
the Emperor proclaimed him so when he
forced choked his pregnant wife when he
tried to murder his former mentor
definitely when he slaughtered
younglings in the Jedi Temple Sebastian
Shaw is the face of Anakin after
he has come back from that darkness
after he made the decisive choice to
reject evil his is the face of
redemption in the face Luke should see
at the end George Lucas did all this
work to build up a sobering chilling
catharsis to unmask his great villain
and then he dashes all those powerful
emotions by injecting a stranger if your
first viewing of this series is in
release order has the resident final
image of the greatest trilogy of all
time
Lucasfilm Disney I beg you do not let
this edition live on as the version of
Return of the Jedi that future
generations of fans imprint as Star Wars
Canon when they discover this on
streaming platforms just fix it and
reupload told me George Lucas you're our
only hope
hey looks that aside kudos to return of
the Jedi as a whole for taking a beloved
franchise in a direction that forced us
to both find our inner child and accept
change but what do you think about
Lucas's changes to the original trilogy
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
vas and subscribe to our WikiLeaks
podcast feed for all of our Star Wars
analysis thank you for joining me in god
George Lucas is editing me over with
Hayden Christensen
[Music]